distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen let me first of all thank the
foreign policy community of indonesia
for the invitation
it doesn't happen very often to address
such a numerous and qualified audience
from so many different countries
today
all of humanity faces many of the same
challenges
we all want to end this long pandemic
we all want an economic recovery
that is built on solid foundations
we are all concerned by the rise in
energy prices
and we all see the impact of climate
change on each one of our countries
our success depends entirely
on whether we can get together
and focus on our shared interests
this is true even for regions like ours
that are geographically distant from one
another
just think about these simple facts
trade exchanges between europe and the
indo-pacific region are higher than
between any other regions in the world
and 40 percent of europe's foreign trade
flows through the south china sea
the indo-pacific produces 60
of the global gdp
but also 60 of global co2 emissions
what happens on your side of the world
has massive implications for europe and
vice versa
so we are
caring about cooperation with asia
and we also care about cooperation with
your region
it is positive that president biden and
president xi
met virtually recently
they agreed on possible fields of
cooperation
such as climate action
and we hope that this dialogue will
continue
and help to deal with important issues
concerning your region and beyond
the military buildup in the indo-pacific
waters
and along its shores
has been a constant feature of the last
few years
military spending in the region has
risen like nowhere else in the world
new weapons have been tested new bases
have been built
and this can only threaten stability and
growth well beyond your region
for europe the respect of international
law and international agreements
is the foundation of a peaceful world
we are always ready to stand up for our
values
at the same time
europe's engagement in the indo-pacific
seeks cooperation beyond geopolitical
divides
in these times of shared challenges
we are offering to work with every
country
that wishes to do so when our interests
coincide
today i would like to focus on three
promising fields for our cooperation
with countries in the indo-pacific
first
vaccines to end the pandemic
second climate action
and third creating new links between our
regions both physically and digital
on vaccines
at the last g20 in rome
we europeans insisted to agree on a
common target
to vaccinate 70
on the global population by mid next
year
we did that because we know that we can
only get out of this pandemic together
if the virus keeps spreading even just
in one world region
new variants may emerge
the pandemic will only be over when all
continents are safe
likewise this year has shown us how
interconnected our economies are
allow me to use one example you are all
familiar with
last september
there was a surge in covet cases in
southeast asia
many factories in your part of the world
had to shut down
the economic shock wave spread to the
whole world
global supply chains for cars computers
and smartphones were disrupted
because of the lack of electronic
components
not only is our health connected
but also our economic recovery
so we are really glad that the headline
goal of indonesia's upcoming g20
presidency will be
recovering together
recovering stronger
the first step towards a strong recovery
is equitable global access to covet
vaccines
this was europe's policy from the very
outset of the crisis
when you read about vaccine diplomacy in
the indo-pacific
europe is not the first power to be
mentioned by media reports
but let me give you a few figures
from december 2020
the european union has exported over
550 million doses
of covet vaccines to countries in asia
pacific
all in all we have exported almost 1.2
billion doses
to 150 countries in the world
more than we have used inside europe
even if we are far away continent we
have been an essential part of asian
vaccine supplies
beyond exports europe has also been a
strong supporter of global vaccine
solidarity
we were among the leading forces behind
the creation of kovacs
the global facility providing vaccines
to low and middle income countries
the european union and its member states
we call ourselves team europe
have contributed over one third of the
kovacs budget
and roughly one third of kovacs doses
are going to asia pacific
yet we know that we need to step up the
world's vaccine manufacturing capacities
and this is why in our new indo-pacific
strategy
we propose
to work together on pharmaceutical
supply chains
europe wants to be your partner
in ending the pandemic
and strengthening the world's health
infrastructure for the future
second on climate action
by the end of this decade more than 70
percent of the rise in global energy
demand
will come from the indo-pacific
the question we all face is
can asia get the energy it needs
in a way that is sustainable for our
planet and for our environment
i am convinced that the answer is a
strong
yes
because this is what the european
experience shows
since 1990
europe's economy grew by 60
while our co2 emissions went down by 30
sustainable growth is possible if we
invest decisively in a cleaner economy
so when i look at the outcome of cop 26
in glasgow the glass is only half full
on the one hand climate neutrality is
now a shared global goal
and we have also set an intermediate
target
to cut emissions by 45
by 2030.
on the other hand we are still not on
track to limit global warming to 1.5
degrees celsius
many countries still lack the necessary
level of ambition
on top of that an agreement on phasing
out coal power
was watered down in the 11th hour
and industrialized nations failed to
commit enough resources
to help developing countries in the
transition
fulfilled its promise
but others did not
so
what next after glasgow
europe will keep working to speed up the
transition towards a clean economy
for instance in glasgow we announced a
new contribution to the asean catalytic
green finance facility
this facility is an investment fund
that we have been supporting for a few
years now
and it has already financed for some
important projects across the region
such as a massive solar park in cambodia
which is producing the cheapest solar
energy in southeast asia
there is a sustainable way to growth
and europe wants to be your partner
towards a carbon neutral and circular
economy in our mutual interest
and this leads me to my third point
what does europe have to offer on
connectivity and infrastructure
when we invest on big infrastructure
abroad
we do care about making business but
we also care about respecting the
environment
we also care about workers rights
and preventing the exploitation of
children
we also care about users rights in the
digital world
and guaranteeing that they always have
control over their data
and we also care about the financial
sustainability of every single project
in a partnership with europe
what you see is what you get
we want to create links
not dependencies
these are the principles that will
underpin our new connectivity strategy
called global gateway
global gateway will build on the
connectivity partnerships
that we have established with india and
japan
and the ministerial statement on
connectivity with asean
global gateway will focus on creating
the sustainable connections of the
future
for instance new international markets
for clean hydrogen
or new partnership in the digital field
countries like india and japan the
republic of korea and singapore are
powerhouses when it comes to new
technologies
from artificial intelligence to quantum
computing
and we share a similar approach
to these new technologies
one that is centered on human beings and
their rights
for like-minded partners like us
cooperation on digital innovation
should be a no-brainer
the opportunities for future-oriented
connectivity cooperation
countless
and to support it
we will invest through our global
gateway
the indo-pacific is home to some of the
largest democracies in the world
including indonesia
we share many of the same values
we are open democracies built on
diversity
and it is no chance that indonesia and
the european union share the same motto
united in diversity
we all want to build an international
order based on rules
not on confrontation
one where conflicts are settled
peacefully
and well global commons such as global
trade routes
remain open and accessible to all
these shared values are the main reason
why europe sees the indo-pacific as a
partner of choice
where other powers can only see new
fault lines between changing spheres of
influence
europe sees new possibilities for
cooperation on our mutual interests
and i look forward to indonesia's g20
presidency
to the upcoming asem summit
and our summit with asean next year
to expand our common work towards a
sustainable recovery
europe wants to be more present and more
active in your part of the world
to deepen trade links strengthen global
supply chains
to invest together in green and digital
technologies
to keep our people safe
we are a world apart
but we feel like we have never been
closer
thank you very much for the invitation
and let me wish you a great discussion
at this global town hall